ils ont voulu dénoncer l'inaction du
gouvernement pour lutter contre les
logements passoires en france des
militants de greenpeace des membres de
la fondation abbé pierre mais aussi des
locataires se sont mobilisés ce matin à
paris une action coup de poing devant le
ministère de la transition écologique
ils demandent au gouvernement
d'accélérer la rénovation des logements
immobilisations pour des mesures plus
ambitieuses au sein des lois climat
actuellement en discussion à l'assemblée
nationale
ce qu'on demande c'est un calendrier
plus ambitieux d'éradication de toutes
les passoires thermiques et pas
seulement celles en location qui
représente que 2 millions de logements
sur les 5 millions de façon thermique de
compte la france donc c'est un
engagement qui avait été fait en 2000 19
heures de la loi énergie climat
d'éradiquer tous les deux les passoires
thermiques en 2028
et pourtant ce n'est pas ce qui figure
dans la loi actuellement pour nous on va
ça ne va pas assez loin et eu quelques
progrès ces dernières années c'est vrai
mais on n'est pas sur les ambitions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
il n'y a pas d'obligation généralisée de
rénover les passoires énergétiques
c'est simplement d obligation pour les
propriétaires bailleurs à une échéance
2025 2026 ou 2030 4 en fonction de deux
niveaux énergétique de logements donc
c'est très lointain aucune obligation
pour les propriétaires occupants alors
qu'on sait que les incitations simple ne
suffisent pas
je suis moi-même habitants de logements
passoires avec ma famille c'est très dur
on paie environ entre 1500 et 2000 euros
pour se chauffer c'est même pas pour
chauffer c'est à peu près pour avoir une
température normale pour nos enfants qui
t'ont pas trop malades parce qu'ils
tombent souvent malades
on est les deux millions en france on
souffre énormément de ces passoires
énergétiques ca/logement des années 80
qui a pas d'isolation n'y a pas de
double vitrage le vent s'engouffre le
froid on se les murs ils sont froids on
est obligés de se couvrir en ait à payer
on assure habillé en maison en secours
avec 2,3
ouverture le soir sinon on a trop propre
et il ya la moisissure et c'est vraiment
très cd c'est pas une situation on peut
vivre alors qu'on paie un loyer
c'est pas normal